oh
Chris
I'm dying I was dying earlier today and
then I died
now I'm dead I had to cancel a date with
Shawna boy dweep and I really like her
do you think she'll still like me
now that I'm dead what is this
it's food poisoning
I have it too I did not sleep for one
second last night and I cracked the
bottom of the toilet bowl God don't say
that has anybody talked to Tom I can't
even imagine what that tiny little man
must be feeling like I have voided more
than Tom's body weight in the last 12
hours alone he might have just
disappeared off the Earth we need to
call him we must reach out to him
I can't do it
howdy neighbors welcome to human Farm
here's your animal feed please don't
feed the animals
really really cool I
lie statement it's making that you know
we're all in cages in a way yeah it's
actually about death and the city yeah I
see that now
hi Oren
can't believe it I made a mistake the
parents are the same no matter time nor
place so to all you kids all across the
land no need to argue parents just don't
understand
all right
thank you thank you
just a little something I know
so what's up uh someone is on fire in
ramsit park they need you to get down
there right away
oh my God so I made my desk out of
silver M M's but they do not make silver
M M's so I spray painted them okay those
are poisonous so no one eat them yeah
duh
go throw up I didn't need any go throw
up
[Music]
I'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing and I'm putting him down
[Music]
there's no stairs how do I get it stage
oh
it's still five hundred dollars
oh because
you know what dynazash out of the way
yeah
oh God ambulance a different ambulance
than what I ran into you might want to
borrow this oh no one wants her dirty
underwear but it's not dirty underwear
it's a white flag and you may as well
start waving it right now especially
won't be waving as your decapitated head
on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good Lord
yep follow it to me guys just go into
the parking lot for normal government
reasons
sorry I can't go through with this I was
gonna pull a prank
no yeah I've hired these guys in ski
masks to kidnap us and I was gonna
pretend to be a hero they were going to
shoot me and drive the van into the
river and that's when the divers would
go in pull you guys out of the water and
I would be standing on the shore like
hey get pranked much
though I haven't got these squibs from
his special effects guy and I was gonna
say this code word and that's when I
would push this button no
[Applause]
he's got his back come on fight me no no
no no no no no
nice yeah oh my God Andy I am so sorry
oh Psych
blood capsules
what yeah I wanted to shock you into
expressing your anger and that way my
nose is broken oh my God I gotta go to
the hospital oh my god did it feel good
each department will be getting blue
bins
do you need to go to the dentist Ron I
don't like dentists just a second
hey no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
[Applause]
no
no
no
oh my god wow looking good yeah I mean I
wish we had built one of those elevators
that comes up from under the stage you
know the rock Arena kind of thing
they're coming
what is your problem nothing's changed
exchanged please set the bat on fire
excuse me I did okay is that what you
want to eat we're fine we're fine take
it easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
oh
God
oh yeah
done it the usual place
[Laughter]
are you in a lot of pain I was shot in
the head with a shotgun
okay
Donna Donna
[Applause]
are you okay what is it your heart are
you having trouble breathing
open your mouth get Grandma's mustache
open your mouth
coyote trap dude yeah we got like a huge
Vermin problem I mean it wouldn't be
meaning to call somebody about it but
you know nobody get on the phone you're
the peel you would be calling that is so
trippy
[Music]
hey game over Tammy
oh my God I am so turned on right now
what is wrong with you oh yeah tell me
you're not feeling this you are so crazy
[Music]
you're too late
[Music]
I mean I'd do anything for Ron even
spend a whole night fighting his crazy
ex-wife
I think I'm safe
just gotta be tired by now